I wanted to have on a Jeff Fletcher he's
the Angels beat writer for the Orange
County Register because we were talking
about this the other day when the ballot
comes out Otani will be on there I want
to I hope he's in the homeland Derby but
can he make could he make the roster at
two different positions I'm curious
about that Jeff kind enough to join us
hey Jeff thanks for joining us
sure thanks for having me explain this
with the the ballot for the all-star
game
Oh tani would be on there as a regular
everyday player and then he would be
eligible to be picked by the manager for
pitching as well you know we haven't
really given that a whole lot of thought
until you just mentioned it but that
that sounds reasonable I mean they don't
vote fans don't vote for pitchers so
obviously it has to be on there as a d-h
so I'm guessing that would be how it
would work yes but I'm also looking I'm
curious with he had comments where he
said through an interpreter that he
wanted to play more but I think the
Angels are doing the right thing by you
know yes you want to say that publicly
but I think privately they it's a long
season for him he'll hit that rookie
wall but how much do you see him as an
everyday player as we move forward well
I mean he's available to him every day
except the day before and after he
pitches and the day he's pitching so at
least four days a week plus off days so
that's maybe three and a half days a
week and so far there have been two
games he's been available he hasn't
played so you know I think that's
probably reasonable going forward he's
gonna probably play an average of three
days a week maybe some weeks only to
probably rarely four but I think you
know they really have to be very careful
with this it's like a he's a very
fragile I'm not these presidents very
valuable and it's a very strange thing
they're doing with him so they don't
want to break him so to speak if I said
a month ago six weeks ago that Otani
would have this kind of start what would
you have said probably not have been
surprised on the pitching part I would
have been surprised on the hitting part
I think there was reasonable skepticism
about him as a hitter even before spring
training before we saw what happened in
spring training
just because I think the scouting
reports were that he was you know better
as a pitcher and
you know as a hitter in Japan they
didn't pitch him inside very much
obviously the pitching that is good in
Japan doesn't see as much velocity all
these other things and Plus you know
hitters in the major leagues that are
everyday hitters they say how difficult
is it to hit if you're not doing it
every single day you know and he's just
by definition gonna take three days off
a week where he's not really gonna hit
so you add all that together and I think
there's a lot of skepticism that he can
be a hitter you know indefinitely and
they're still you know reasonable
skepticism that this is going to go on
forever but so far he's doing great he
said you know xxx bats which is not a
ton and he's doing it very well so far
it's I guess give people a sense of what
it's like for him with the media
certainly the the Japanese media
covering him what's that like on a daily
basis well it's not really quite the
circus that you would imagine there's
probably an extra thirty members of the
Japanese media there on an everyday
basis on the basic pitches it goes up to
maybe 75 or 100 that's a lot as well you
know but he it's very separated where
he'll do his little press conference
after the games only he never talks
before the game they take him out into a
separate area it's not in the clubhouse
he talked to the American media first of
which there's usually five six eight
people and he doesn't with his
interpreter and then he goes in talk to
the Japanese media and doesn't without
the interpreter was so it goes a lot
faster and you know it's probably a
total commitment for him of about 12 to
15 minutes four times a week so it's not
it's not a huge inconvenience I don't
think for him or for the other players
so it is so far and I've been so that
any jealousy and the part of the
veterans there so far know so far it's
sort of been the opposite they've kind
of rallied around him because of the
criticism around him during spring
training and people that were sort of
saying he was a bust and he shouldn't be
in the majors and they kind of said hey
you know that's ridiculous this is
spring training we can see how good this
guy is so they're sort of defending and
you know I don't know two months from
now if everybody is still fighting you
know in awe about when he got a hit then
you know maybe it'll be different
but for now it's it's not too bad you
see pitching tomorrow against the red
song yes yes okay if I said and I know
you're gonna hate me for this you could
have the future of these players
starting right now Bryce Harper Mike
Trout or Shohei Otani am i starting now
so I don't already get the last six
years of a drought no nope right today
oh man that is a tough question I would
probably take still trout just because
he is uh he still he's only three years
older than she was
today and you know he's up you know rock
solid absolute guaranteed you know what
he's going to give you Donnie is still
you know he's a pitcher that can get
hurt we don't know about the hitting
thing you know because he's trying to do
two things at once he's maybe
deteriorating from each of them by doing
both I would still take trout probably
all right well at least you paused I
thought it might be one of those it's a
it's a given because you watch trout
every single day but you know the the
fascination with Otani and what he's
done so far and of course in this day
and age you have to have your hot take
and has to be immediate so you have to
have your opinion right now then I play
it like five years from now Jeff Lynn Oh
Donnie's back in the Japanese league and
then I say how could you possibly say
that that's how we do this tiny kidding
there hey Jeff thanks for joining us
sure thank me that's Jeff Fletcher the
Angels beat writer for the Orange County
Register no we wouldn't do that we
wouldn't plate like five years from now
we've been known to do that but I I
wouldn't do that I just went on a rant
last Friday where you know the the media
disc used to negative stories so I can't
do that now for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]